well Supreme Court Justice Ruth Bader
Ginsburg is recovering at a hospital
here in New York City this morning after
successfully undergoing lung surgery
doctors removed two cancerous nodules
from her left lung on Friday she is 85
years old the Supreme Court said there
was no evidence of any remaining disease
Kenneth Craig is here with the latest
Kenneth what good news do you have well
good morning to you Michele yesterday
surgery is just the most recent major
health problem for the courts oldest
justice it's Ginsburg's third treatment
for cancer since 1999 and it comes just
one month after she fell and fractured
her ribs doctors came across the
malignant nodules on Ginsburg slug
incidentally as they treated her rib
injuries in November and less than a
week ago in an interview set to air in
January the justice was upbeat about her
health how's your health it's fine thank
you
and those ribs you busted almost repair
an appointee of President Bill Clinton
Ginsburg leads the Supreme Court's
liberal wing she's gained cult status
known to some of her fans as the
notorious RBG she was the subject of a
documentary last summer and her
trailblazing fight against gender
discrimination is the subject of the
forthcoming film on the basis of sex you
don't get to tell me when to quit
at a screening for that movie last week
she told the audience she was getting
ready to resume her workout routine
which she showcased for late-night host
Stephen Colbert back in March Ginsburg's
resilience was on display just hours
after Friday surgery she cast a decisive
vote as the Supreme Court struck down a
key piece of President Trump's
immigration policy an attempted ban on
asylum for immigrants who illegally
crossed the us-mexico border CBS Sunday
morning anchor Jane Pauley interviewed
Ginsburg in 2016 the Supreme Court
justice says she hopes to serve until
the next Democratic president can
appoint her replacement
my age you have to take it year by year
so this year I know I'm fine what will
be next year or the next year I can't
predict justice Ginsberg is expected to
remain in the hospital for the next few
days it's not clear yet if she'll be
back on the bench when the court
reconvenes on January 7th but in more
than 25 years as a Justice Ginsburg has
never missed a day of whirl
arguments pretty remarkable strength
personified that one person kind of
thank you very much